Correct answer is $10. Recall that the formula for the standard error of the
mean is the sample standard deviation divided by the square root of n. So
here's how we calculate that. 50 divided by the square root of 25 is 50 over 5.
50 divided by 5 is 10. This $10 tells us that we expect sample means, to differ
from the true population mean by $10, on average. So, remembering the sampling
distribution of the mean, the mean of that distribution is equal to the
population mean mu, which is 151. We expect most sample means to fall one state
of deviation above and one state of deviation below. So we expect most sample
means to differ from mu by $10 on average. So most sample means should fall
between 141 and 161.